surprise winning author and biologist EO
Wilson came up with what is now known as
the half-earth idea it involves making
half the planet a human-free Zone
leaving nature to do what it can to
stabilize itself
this means that the current global
population of roughly 7.7 billion people
would have to make do with half the
space we currently have
and for a lot of people that's just not
feasible
cordoning off half the world for extreme
conservation would displace roughly 1
billion people
most of them from low-income backgrounds
think of those parts of the world where
overpopulation is severe and then
imagine that situation everywhere
but housing isn't our only concern we
also need food and fresh water to
survive